What I'll be presenting on today is work that
I came into
that was already ongoing, Linda Niccolai,
who was
one of my mentors during my postdoc along
with Robert Heimer,
both of them are co-investigators, co-PIs on
a study of injection drug users,
gay men and and their sexual partners in St. Petersburg, Russia.
And I have to say Russia because people
would think I mean Florida otherwise.
So I did not design the study. I cannot take credit
for its creativity, for its insight.
I'm analyzing the data, so I'm here to present
really mostly their work.
So, the first thing you see about this slide probably
is that it's about Russia, and we don't hear
a lot about HIV in Russia, so what the heck
were we doing there?
St. Petersburg is a lovely place.
I'll give you the little Lonely Planet version
of it
in just a couple seconds. It was built,
it was commissioned pretty much in the early
eighteenth century by Peter the Great.
It's called the Venice of the Baltic 'cause
it's built on forty two little
islands and islets separated by canals,
and you can take cool
like Vaporetti through it, and it's
incredibly beautiful, and
it's like done in this
totally Baroque style.
It's a trippy place. It's where the Hermitage is.
So why are we in Russia?
Why'd we go all the way there to study HIV?
We have plenty of HIV in North America.
There's a lot of HIV in the developing world
that we know of.
This might seem
like kind of an esoteric place to be doing
it,
but you know, I'm an epidemiologist. I want
to go where the disease is. That's why I work
with sexually transmitted infections among
homosexually active men because
we're number one with the bullet with HIV in
this country. We're the ones who get HIV more
than anyone else. That's true in a lot of countries,
so what's the interest in Russia?
Epidemiologists…you're all
in the public health program, so you know
what this is,
the water pump
outside the John Snow Pub  in London. It's
like, we've got water pumps here. What are we going
all the way to Russia to find a
problematic water pump for?
I'll give you a little background on Russia, and
it'll lead up to why we're doing an HIV study
there.
Russia has been…can you hear me okay?
Okay. Russia's been through a lot in the
twentieth century. Unless you just
beamed down from Mars, you know that.
It started in the
early twentieth century as
a Czarist state, which had only recently
gotten rid of serfdom. It was feudalism.
Most of the citizens were not citizens. They
were actually slaves of their vassals.
And then went through a revolution…World
War I, a révolution,
World War II, which killed thirty million
Russians. This is a memorial…a carved relief
by one of the two places in the Neva river,
which when frozen during the two
winters that it was blockaded
by the Nazi army,
which was
one of two places in the city where you could
get water
with your bucket and then
run home hoping that a sniper didn't pick
you off while you
got home. So
these are kind of tough people. They've
been through a lot.
What brought us
to HIV is things that have happened in
the more recent past.
In 1989 through '91
really was the period of transition
from Marxism
to a capitalist economy and a huge
number,
a great deal of turmoil happened with that.
It's you know, for the Americans in the
audience, we're used to a very stable
form of government here.
Imagine that changed
within a short period of time.
That was a difficult transition period, but
what was even a
bigger deal was the economic collapse that
came in 1994.
As my colleagues in St. Petersburg,
as one has said to me,
we thought it was hard to get bread and milk
in the grocery stores under communism,
but then after the economic collapse it
was just ridiculous.
Elderly people just stopped receiving pension
checks,
paychecks were no longer being cut even
though people were
showing up to the factory for work every day
and every week,
the system,
the infrastructure of the country basically
fell apart.
It's one of the bizarre cases
that we know of where like expectancy for a
country actually went down
during the early 1990s.
That's pretty much unprecedented
except in some in some places in sub-Saharan
Africa due to HIV.
This was primarily due to other factors.
"The striking rise in Russian mortality
is beyond the peacetime experience of industrialized
countries with a
five-year decline in life expectancy in four years time.
Many factors appear to be operating simultaneously including
economic and social
instability,
high rates of tobacco and alcohol consumption,
poor nutrition, depression
and deterioration of the health care system."
That appeared in JAMA
about
twelve years ago.
I would throw in there too the interpersonal
violence and suicide also took a
great number of lives, particularly those of
men
during the
post-
Soviet period.
Okay, what's that got to do with HIV?
It's almost like a war.
More people die of infectious diseases following
a war or during the war than
usually die
from bullets or shrapnel.
With turmoil
comes ill health
effects, and this is kind of a case study in that.
This appeared by,
he's got an Armenian name, but he's a Russian writer,
in the
Journal of STD and AIDS, and I think it
sounds a little bit like a moral panic,
what he's getting to here,
but it also frames the issue, I think. "Fundamental
cultural and social
and economic transitions happened during this
period.
Sustained economic
crises worsened the quality of life.
We have poverty, joblessness,
refugee migration and
fatalism concerning the future.
And we have social acceptance of prostitution,
which
has its pros and cons.
Temporary sexual relationships among young people
and declining age at first sex, and whether or
not you think these are
morally or ethically shiny and good for
you, they can have
deleterious health effect.
So,
the big thing that happened
that concerns HIV
during this period of turmoil
was remember you had a lot of out of work
people,
you had a lot of people who were not receiving
government stipends that they were used to
including
a huge number
of veterans of the Afghan war, many
of whom were disabled and didn't really have
a way of of surviving,
who took advantage of existing
drug trade routes coming in from
not the golden triangle of southeast Asia
but the golden triangle of southwest Asia.
Following the Afghan war
and following the turmoil that happened with
the Soviet excursion into Afghanistan in
1980 and its aftermath,
a lot of poppies grown there, kind of like what we saw
with the Taliban not so long ago.
And
black tar, heroin, which was similar to the stuff
that comes from Mexico,
its very minimally processed,
called chyorny,
which means black...
It's essentially opium; it's
gunk...
was getting dragged into Russian cities
very very cheaply.
And what happened
is a huge proportion of a birth cohort
became addicted to heroin.
We know that in the United States
the number one birth cohort year for picking up heroin was 1955.
And although it hasn't been
formally quantified, all the anecdotal evidence
suggests
that the years that people most picked up heroin,
the birth years, were
to 1982.
So you've got this bolus of folks who picked
up heroin
moving to the demographic python
as time goes by.
And they
acquire and transmit HIV.
Say, I'll just go to the next slide.
So before we did this study what led us to do
a study of HIV among injection drug
users in St Petersburg?
Well we had
some evidence that there was a problem.
There were, you know, studies of varying validity
and generalizability that were showing
two to four percent of the IV users in the city
were infected in '98, then
eleven to eighteen percent by 2000,
thirty percent by 2002.
Looks like we've got an emerging
infection problem here.
What we now know independent of this study
I'll be presenting here but that
contributes to it is Russia now has
one of the fastest-growing epidemics in the
world.
About one percent of the Russian population
is HIV infected.
That translates to half a million to 1.5
million russians given
the appropriate confidence intervals around
everything.
But unlike many other countries, unlike other industrialized
countries, the vast majority of the infections
are among injection drug users.
We also saw some other indicators that injection
drug users were not the only population being
affected.
Positive
test prevalence…HIV testing is done
for almost all women who present at hospital
to give birth.
If they're getting prenatal care it's done then,
and if they haven't
had prenatal care
they do a rapid test and stat they get her
the HAART that will prove that
neonatal transmission.
The
positive test prevalence went from nothing in
in the city to almost one and a half percent by
2002.
Not huge numbers, but actually that's
a pretty high
positive test prevalence for pregnant women
in the developed world.
The good thing is most, you know, nearly all
these women do get
HAART...
nevirapine, rather.
The rapid rise was what concerned us.
Another population that did,
37 percent of
St Petersburg street youth
were found to be HIV infected.
The problem was…it's clear
that it's going to be
higher among those who inject, but
then it was also higher among those using
inhalants, and you don't get HIV from inhalants.
It was independently associated with being an orphan.
And with being a double orphan more than a
single orphan,
and those aren't things that transmit HIV, so
clearly social disruption was playing
a part in this.
And then what led directly to this study was
was they noticed that between
2001 and 2003, the proportion
of newly diagnosed cases, newly reported cases,
went from five to twenty percent,
which means…which was a
possible indicator that
HIV was no longer just being transmitted within
the core group of injection drug users, but
then
spreading on to their sex partners, spilling over
to the other people at risk.
And
the question was will enough of this happen
to sustain
a generalized heterosexual epidemic
like you see in other areas of the world.
So this is the group that got together to
talk about those questions. There were
four sites in the US including us partnering
with the biomedical center in St Petersburg,
the sexual acquisition transmission of
HIV cooperative agreement program,
to look at the role of sexual transmission
within cores,
meaning gay men
and drug users. They included non-injection
drug users because of so much sexual transmission
going on between crack cocaine users
and to look at what the
overall epidemic effect would be
to people outside those groups.
Sorry, didn't switch the slide around.
This is part of the background of why we did
this study because
the study included gay men
I gave you background on IDUs, on other
populations in St Petersburg,
now a little late I'll give you
the information that we had about gay men
in Russia
prior to doing this study, which was basically
jack.
Pretty much everything I mean you know you
go to the latest
information on the Euro surveillance website.
Eurosurveillance dot
euro or something.
The latest thing they've got for
Russia is one small study, four hundred guys,
total convenience sample
of guys showing up at gay bars. They
didn't even weight them
by how often they went to bars,
so it's really just a study of how many people
were standing around a bar at any
given moment.
Not the most methodologically strong
survey, but it found one and a half percent
had reported an HIV-positive test.
This was pretty much all we
knew about gay men and HIV in Russia
to that point.
But
thirty seven
percent had not used a condom
for their last act of anal sex.
Huge proportion of sex trade.
About one in five
had either paid for sex or had been paid for
sex.
Thirty seven percent also had female partners.
So there's a lot of
potential,
not a lot of HIV, but a lot of
potential for transmission within the population
and then outside the population.
So that made us want to study gay men in Russia
too.
The methods that … used, it was pretty much a
cross-sectional study.
Between 2005 and 2008, they sampled
from the two core groups
and also their male and female sexual partners.
So
we had two core respondent-driven sampling,
respondent-driven sampling
begins with seed participants.
Like let's say you're going to be
in a study of public health students, and
you get into the study the traditional way
by like
maybe answering an ad.
What happens then is
you're asked to recruit
other members of your population because you
know those people,
and
because you got paid twenty bucks to be in
the study,
they'll pay the other person you recruit
twenty bucks, but then they'll give you five
because you successfully recruited
somebody else.
It's not so much to twist your arm
to twist other people's arms,
but it's enough to say thanks and make you
not feel
taken advantage of if you actually do it.
It differs from a snowball sample on that
at each step, with each recruitment,
you weight by the inclusion probabilities.
So you say if
eight of the ten other public health students
that you know are female,
but the one person you recruited was male,
that's kind of not random recruitment, so
you can do
through the magic of mathematical waiting
allegedly
with long enough recruitment chains,
you can get your sample to
emulate a probability sample.
But, yeah right.
It doesn't really happen
in real life. It's a lot better in theory.
It turns out
that RDS seems to be a better recruitment tool
than a sampling tool.
It's somewhere between just a crude snowball
sample and an actual probability sample,
and that's why we're hosting a
small symposium in the spring called RDS 2.0
to see what we can do
with technique.
Blood specimens to test for HIV were tested…
we ran ELISAs and Western blots to
confirm the positives.
I don't have it on this slide, but we also tested for...
we did syphilis serologies, tested for gonorrhea, chlamydia,
and HEP C and B.
We used anonymous structured questionnaires
using CASI,
which is basically that you take your
questionnaire on a laptop
instead of paper and pencil,
and we asked for information on sexual risk behaviors
and then information about
up to five most recent sexual partners
and got the information about social networks
that I described earlier that you needed to
do the weighting.
And here's
what we got. We got
669 IDUs, 231
homosexually active men, and those don't overlap
because the guys who did overlap those
two groups
were 22,
all of 22, so...
We don't have a lot of power to look
at homosexually active men here, but
we have more,
and we have probably a better sample
of data than in previous studies.
The HIV...
0:18:04.580,0:18:06.940
the prevalence of HIV antibody
among the injection drug users is huge. It's 44 percent.
That's a lot.
That was higher
even as a follow up to thirty.
That's a huge number of people.
Among
homosexually active men who didn't inject
drugs, it was 7 percent,
which is
definitely present. It's about
half
what you would see in a city its size
in the United States where...
or are about three-quarters of what you would
see in Europe.
What's interesting here is
the gay men who injected drugs looked a lot
more like...
like the drug injectors who weren't gay men
than the gay men who didn't inject.
So
their risk
is
you know, possibly coming from injection rather than sex.
We don't know yet.
Hepatitis C:
nearly universal,
nearly ubiquitous among the people who injected
and a heavy burden of STIs among anybody.
I mean, you screen any group of
people, and you get
prevalence for bacterial sexually transmitted
infections of six, eight and fourteen percent.
That's a lot of people with chlamydia or gonorrhea
on board.
The proportion
of the people who were positive who were previously
diagnosed
is pretty low. In this country
what proportion of people with HIV don't
know if they have HIV? Do you know?
Yeah, it's about twenty percent.
Yeah, here
we saw
the proportion who were previously diagnosed was
42 with the injection drug users, so
it was
fifty eight
who didn't know
they had HIV.
Sixty nine percent of the MSM didn't
know they had HIV, so
much, much lower
coverage with testing even though
most of them had been tested in the past.
Just wasn't enough.
So we looked at characteristics associated
with HIV infection and risky sex
for
both groups.
I'll just present it for
HIV infection
for IDs today.
We
controlled for a bunch of
potential covariates. We didn't want to take it to far
because we didn't want it to
be a fishing expedition,
because
we didn't have that much n to work with
and I didn't want any spurious
p values. But these are the usual suspects.
I'll just give you the adjusted odds ratios.
This is the odds,
these are the adjusted odds ratios for testing
HIV positive
if you were a non-gay injection drug user
in Russia.
The women were more likely to test positive.
The people who were…who had
active employment, less.
People who were...who had a history of incarceration,
more.
And people who resided with their family
were more likely to test positive, and that
is an interesting thing on a
few different levels actually because
one,
it's an indicator of socio-economic status.
Who lives with their family when they're an
adult?
Well, people who don't have the money to live
on their own because no one in their right
mind would do that by choice.
And
it also means that you don't
get to shoot up in the kitchen table, do you? You know?
You're not going to do it in front of mama and papa.
You know, you're a...
it's just not going to work.
So
it's associated in some
studies with unhygenic
injection practices
because you're doing it on the sly.
We looked at the
homosexually active men where we included
the IDs in here because we needed to conserve
n by any means possible,
and
HIV infection was associated with being
older than...
age twenty four or older,
having a history of drug injection,
and negatively associated with full- or part-time
employment.
Things changed a little because we had this
funny situation
where
we had a fair number of men…we had about fifteen
guys.
Everybody got a global question: do you have sex
with men? Do have sex with women? Or do you
sex with both?
And about fifteen guys said
I only have sex with women.
And we had others who
told us they had sex with men and women, but
this number said
only women.
Then they went on to tell us about the two
or three male sex partners that they'd had
when we asked them who the last people you'd
had sex with were.
But for
coding reasons, just for skip patterns
in the computer program,
they didn't get questions about so the
last time you were with
this guy,
you know, who you've given the initials
TR or whatever,
what did you do with him? Did you have sex
with a condom? Did you have sex without a condom?
You know,
is it on the internet? You know, what did you
do?
A ton of the invasive questions we would ask.
And they didn't answer those
things because they weren't given the questions,
so we weren't able to assess
their condom use, which was
highly annoying.
So what I did is I limited
this to...
Well, guess what, okay.
I limited this. Actually this 253 is wrong.
It's actually down by about twenty,
no, by about fifteen.
But rather than being an injection drug user,
the greatest risk
when I was able to assess what your
partners were like, like was that last guy
you had sex with a drug injector,
having a partner who injected drugs
was
the highest risk factor.
So what does that tell you? Well we go back
to the earlier slide where we saw that the
HIV prevalence was so much greater
among drug injectors including the gay men
among them
than among gay men.
This is
a bizarre
situation where we might actually see
gay men getting HIV
from the injection drug users.
That's just a postulate at this point. I'm
basing that on few observations, but
we shall see.
The prevalence of risky behavior
among these guys was high.
About twenty percent of them
had ever
participated in sex work, traded
sex for money or drugs.
About a third of them had had sex while high
in the last six months with
one partner or another.
Almost half of them had had any unprotected
sex. And then when I limited it,
I excluded...
Well, it's one thing for you to have unprotected
sex with somebody you met that night. It's
another thing for you to have unprotected
sex
with your partner of five years, and you've both
been HIV tested and...
I excluded those partnerships where they
knew the partner's status and it was a
main partner.
Forty two percent of them
had had
unprotected sex that
is really risky for HIV.
And the proportion
was greater
with all of these,
I think.
No, it was greater for sex while high
but was actually
lower
for unprotected anal sex
for the injection drug users,
yet they have for HIV,
so where is the HIV coming from?
And then I broke down the number of partners
in the last six months with whom the last
act of
anal intercourse was unprotected.
So it's not just this,
you know this
half of people have had unprotected sex
that's the problem.
You know, we had for forty seven percent had
no partners of this.
Thirty two percent had one, but then twenty
percent
of the people,
of the guys in the study had had unprotected
anal sex
with two guys or more
in the last six months.
So this is a hierarchy of risk here.
We not just have
half the guys engaging in a little bit of risk here,
we have
twenty percent of them engaging in a lot of
risk in
a six-month period.
So the only
independent association
for unprotected sex with a male partner
was HIV infection negatively associated.
The negative guys
were much less likely to report
risky sex.
Five of the HIV positive participants reported
unprotected sex with a total of six partners,
but none of them had been previously diagnosed.
And
none of them had been previously diagnosed.
So we didn't have a single guy tell us
who knew he had HIV, right? We tested him for HIV,
we found out whether he had HIV. Have you ever had
a positive test before? Oh yeah, two years
ago.
None of those guys
had told us
that they had
unprotected sex
with another guy.
And we're thinking wow, that's really low.
But in Russia
the laws against
knowingly exposing someone to your HIV are severe.
So we're wondering whether that can be some
reporting bias.
However,
we found
when we looked at female partnerships
that the greatest predictor of having unprotected
sex
with a female partner was having a history of drug
injection.
It's the IDUs
who are crossing over to the females by and
large,
but four percent of them
reported unprotected sex with female partners.
Also four participants, all four participants
were IDUs. None of these
were gay men.
They been previously diagnosed…three had
been previously diagnosed with HIV.
So these guys knew they had HIV and were
having unprotected sex with their female partners.
The funky thing is
of the four women they exposed, all were IDUs,
and two
of those had already told
the participant that they were HIV-positive.
So
maybe these guys are making a decision
about which women to expose
because
it's like well
she had already has HIV, so that's one thing,
or
she's an IDU.
Maybe the decision is to
knowingly
expose an IDU partner more than
a non-IDU partner.
That's speculation. That's the question that
it raises.
So what does this tell us about HIV among
drug injectors in St Petersburg?
A lot of HIV,
particularly compared to what they had
had a few years earlier.
Many times
what the prevalence is in western Europe.
It's similar to what we saw in Harlem and the
south Bronx
at the height of the HIV epidemic here
or at height of the HIV epidemic what
we saw among gay men in San Francisco.
These guys are getting clobbered.
And there are other indicators of rapid transmission
that are
kind of independent from these data.
For instance they were all of the same genotype,
but that's another talk.
A nice thing is it allowed us to estimate
the number of active drug injectors in St Petersburg,
about eighty thousand
give or take three thousand
was a piece that Robert Heimer and I just put out.
That's a lot. If half of those people have
HIV
and it's been going up the way it has, it makes
you wonder at what point this will begin to
saturate
because we really never saw
HIV prevalence above fifty percent
in the United States.
So will it start to slow down?
We don't know.
What does it tell us about homosexually active
men in the city?
The first caveat, the first thing I said when I showed
you this slide is that
we have a small n and our sampling strategy
is limited.
The prevalence of HIV infection is about three-quarters
what it is in western Europe,
which means given the size of the study
it's not that different.
The prevalence of risk behavior
is about the same. About thirty seven
percent of these guys
were taking…no, forty two percent these guys
were taking serious risk.
That's pretty close to what you would see
in Spain or France.
And with HIV seroincidence among gay men
it's about two percent in western
Europe, North America, New Zealand. It's a
little less in Australia.
We can
wonder whether
we're having a similar seroincidence there.
The number of new infections per hundred years
of infected person time.
Here's the funky thing though. In the west,
current prevalence was preceded
by a much greater prevalence.
Ten, fifteen years ago
we had a very high HIV prevalence among gay
men in the United States. It went down for
a while because those guys died.
Because it was before the time of HAART.
If HIV
prevalence among gay men in Russia has been
very low until recently
and we've got these high rates
of unprotected sexual contact between
them,
it's
emerging into a pretty…
I don't want to say naive population because that
means you've never been exposed before. So I'm being
a good epidemiologist.
But what it means is there could be an awful lot
of susceptible guys to infect.
So the incidence could actually wind up being
greater
than what it is in western Europe.
So
if the prevalence until recently
has been low
in Russia what does this mean
with this rate of contact
and the current rate of prevalence
if that's a new rate of prevalence, if that's an
emerging infection?
So we'll have to do more work
to get to that.
It also tells us that we have some questions
about bisexuality, drug injection, and sex work.
We didn't have a lot of information on
the bisexual guys. The ones
who didn't provide it said they were heterosexual.
It's like the t-shirt that was running
around in the nineties that guys wore that said
I'm not gay, but my boyfriend is.
It's weird. It's like who were these other partners?
We had a great
problem getting data on sex work
in this study.
The sex work questions were a little...
were a little dodgy.
So what
we're kind of wondering is whether
these guys who said I have no female partners
meanwhile I'll tell you I had sex with male
partner A and male partner B, but I won't tell
you what I did with them,
we're wondering whether those were sex partners,
or trade sex partners.
And that
this might indicate a lot of our homosexually
active IDUs
trading sex
with men for money or drugs
and not getting recorded as that.
And they could be a source of infection for
both male and female partners.
So in order to address these
situations we need better data on gay men
in Russia, and we're doing… you know, it's a
really changing topography.
This slide I look at, and I go
you know,
what's emerging in Russia is that they have
the opportunities for gay night life
every bit as lame as we have in the United
States.
This is Central Station. It's a gay bar
in St Petersburg, and I got to
tell you, I was there in May,
and the thing that people kept impressing
on me is
this bar could't have been here three years ago.
This couldn't have existed. This is totally new.
That all these people you see up here dancing and
having fun,
this is...
really did feel exciting. It's a
watershed.
The other thing that they've got now, is you see
in the lower left is you can
meet a partner online.
You know, it's easier to find sex online
than it is Dominoes.
And they've got Russian language
websites right now, and
and you can just dial it up,
have someone
in your bed that afternoon.
So what that raises the question of is if
seroprevalence got to seven
percent
without gay bars
and without gay internet hookup sites,
and thirty seven percent of the guys
having unprotected sex in the last six months,
or forty two, rather,
What's it gonna be
with the advent of these new methods of meeting
people?
We just change the whole structure.
There's another thing
that we see, which is
in the post-Soviet era I talked about earlier,
female sex work and trafficking in women
increased along with
transmission risk.
But it
looks like sex work among men
might be transmitting too, might be increasing too.
This picture in the lower left
I took from gaytravel.ru, which which
is a web site
where if you want to go on sex travel
like you can to Thailand,
you can go to Russia.
And you know, this charming guy on the left here
I'm sure is with the other one because
of his great personality.
You know, it's like the cheesiest
picture I've ever seen. It's so scary.
So if that's an emerging thing, that's going to
affect the transmission
as well.
So how are we going to study this stuff?
It raises issues of controlling transmission.
I'll jump back to drug users.
We've got challenges
in both these areas, in addressing transmission among
drug users
and gay men.
Right now in Russia
if you're addicted
to heroin, you've really got one mode
of getting help, which is
you know, the narcologists, the addiction specialists
there are going to
lock you up,
and you're going to withdraw,
which is
a painful and dangerous way
to get off heroin, which is what
the injection drug users use there.
There's no drug substitution there. It's illegal.
You can't get methadone.
The doctor can't prescribe for you.
Pharmacies can sell you syringes.
They don't have needle exchange, but syringes
are legal. The only thing is
every store you go into whether it's the
electronics store I went in to get a
new adaptor--I wanted a second adaptor
for another plug, you know, that kind of thing.
They all have off-duty cops
moonlighting
right by the door
because it's a chaotic environment, and people
will just walk out with stuff otherwise.
So if you're
a heroin addict,
you really don't want to walk up
to
the counter at
their version of RiteAid
and buy a pack of syringes.
You can get beaten up when you leave.
You can get harassed later on.
And we know from
another study that fear of police arrest for
carry the equipment like from
a pharmacy with clean syringes
is associated with risky injection
in the Russian context.
So this fear actually
affects
not just
how we do it HIV prevention work
but how we do HIV prevention research.
Controlling transmission has some overall
challenges to it.
Our work is is affected by
factors in both of our countries, especially
trying to do this cross-cultural work.
Drug users are stigmatized.
You see this like
one of the few needle exchanges the happened
in Russia.
That's a pretty grim place.
Gay men
are stigmatized, not prioritized, despite a huge
epidemiological burden
in both countries.
It's very difficult
for any work with gay men to have legitimacy.
The alarming picture that I have here,
this guy tried to organize a gay pride parade
in Moscow in 2009,
and that's what the mayor
had the cops do to him.
So if you just want to waltz in as
a researcher and say I want
do this important work with this population,
in their country as in ours
it might not get met with the best reception.
Another
real challenge to doing this kind of work
from the perspective of Yale or
a US researcher or even researchers from the UK
or other areas
is there's still
a great deal…you know, our relationship with
Russia is still burdened by
decades of mistrust in the past.
You know, if you remember that song from the 80s.
But if you think it sounds…you know, what's
that old joke: I'm here from the United States
government, and I'm here to help.
It's like that sounds bad enough if you're
American,
but can you imagine if
you're Russian?
Weren't you guys…
didn't you used to have missiles pointing at us?
It's a funky relationship.
So those are all going to be
difficulties that we're going to have to address.
We know little about… you know, we know more about
injection drug use
and
HIV
in Russia,
a great deal more than we used to. Most of
what we know is bad.
And we need to understand where things are
going to peak, whether they're going to, whether
HIV is going to spill over into other populations,
and
part of doing that work is stymied
by
difficult attitudes around drug use.
The same thing is happening
with doing work around gay men.
That's just in its infancy.
But both of these things
have a great
potential for future spread.
So I want to thank
the people that I work with here at Yale
on the study, to the good folks at the
biomedical institute who
we work with. People with Yale CIRA.
Thanks for the money, NIMH. We always
appreciate it, and the good people at NGO Stellit.
And you can't see it.
No, it doesn't really show up well.
This is the John Snow Pub,
which is a great place to go for pint in
the UK.
And this is Robert Heimer who is the PI  of the study
along with our colleagues from Stellit
at a swanky place in St Petersburg.
So,
I can take questions. Thanks.